biden covert advisor says u.s lockdown
of four to six we could control pandemic
and revive the economy
okay go a little higher let's read this
dr michael
ostrohome which by the way if you guys
don't know who he is he
was the first guy that came out on joe
rogan he got like 20 million views
coronavirus adviser to president-elect
joe biden
said a nationwide lockdown would help
bring the virus under control in the u.s
he said the government could borrow
enough money to pay for package that
would never
cover lost income for individuals and
government during a shutdown we could
really watch
ourselves cruising into the vaccine
availability in the first and second
quarter of next year while bringing back
the economy
long before that go a little higher to
see if there's anything else below
go a little higher uh to see whether or
not i'm drawing some references
okay so four to six weeks what do you
think four to six week adam shutting it
down
four to six weeks i mean obviously we're
not we're trying to avoid another
shutdown that's something
that but that's what they're saying to
do right yeah well i mean sometimes
i'm going to play devil's advocate here
the covet is back
we've been saying that it's not been
gone no meaning it was
it was going down over the summer boom
they've been saying it the once the fall
and the cooler weather happens
kobet's back i mean trump's been saying
we're rounding the curve around in the
curve
all over the campaign in my opinion that
swung a lot of voters being like dude we
talking about we're
numbers are going up um
i assume they're thinking is sometimes
you need to take two steps back
in order to take 100 steps forward yeah
so if
i don't think anybody wants a lockdown
anyone who's like yeah
a lockdown yay more masks yay awesome
the economy
but this just comes down to numbers if
it's going to cost us more money and
more stimulus
to keep fighting this pandemic
and the numbers just don't justify the
end zone justify the means if we have to
lock down for a month
in order to be freaking free and clear
you're quoted
you're cool with fortunately i'm not
saying i'm cool with it i'm saying
if these are what experts not talking
heads like us over here
experts are saying we might want to
consider listening to experts on this
obviously our gut instincts are going to
be like another lockdown oh my god
but if this is what it takes we need to
do something about this because how much
money is the
pandemic costing us because our our
economy is not fully functional the
answers are whatever the media decides
to tell you that day i love how people
that voted for biden tell us that covet
is back
how the hell do they know are they the
doctors how do we know this guy isn't a
quack
all right by the way i'm embarrassed he
teaches at the university of minnesota i
think it's the most harmful
thing he could possibly say i think it
is
dangerous i think he should be disbarred
i think it's
terrible what he said another lockdown
would destroy this country
i mean to to an economic degree that i
don't know if we'd be able to get out of
it for a long time and here's the other
thing too
biden is a puppet he will do what
everybody tells him to
he's already been documented to say that
he would shut down the country
if science told him to or if he was
encouraged to
so can you read the tea leaves where
this is going it's headed in exactly
that direction
and and you know what do we really know
covet is back yeah positive tests are
back
are people dying more is it a fatal
disease are our icu units really that
overwhelmed right right
apparently they are we don't know that
we don't know what the media is saying
it we don't know it's true
let's just take the hospitals don't go
texas go all this
all show all and if you can make that
bigger kai be good
have you guys talked to doctors like in
march april may yeah that are actually
in
we did go through go to death yeah go to
death
so death is not up cases are up adam if
you think about it so
do me a favor put them side by side like
put put another page
side by side so we can go to it to go to
another page and put the same exact
search that you just put up covet cases
just tap in coronavirus cases yeah there
you go like that and go to it
and then change from texas to all show
all
so so look at that so if can you make
this smaller and put it right next to
the other one because i want to compare
the two make it smaller
and make the other one yeah so so go to
covet cases cover cases so go
to death because this is how you measure
this like if the cases are
up but death is down it just means it's
not as deadly just so everybody knows
yeah go a little more left and then and
then change it from cases to death on
the left side
yeah so if you look at that can you make
that a little smaller guy or no can you
okay look just look that's fine that's
fine the weight is okay so if you look
at this right here
this is what you see so here it went up
cases went up
so death this is cases okay cases went
up
death went up right at the beginning we
had no clue what we were doing
then death went down june 13
cases flattened okay cases went up we
had one big day here
then it's pretty much been flat even
though the cases have been going up you
don't see a spike going up so
you realize the more cases go up and
death
stays flat you know what it's saying
it's not as deadly
that's what it says i don't that makes
sense or not so if cases are going look
at look how bad
it's the worst it's ever been with cases
right look at over here it's a worse has
been with cases but death is flat
you know so if this spikes then that
means the rate of how deadly it is
is deadly but if cases are going up it
just means kids are going back to school
september kids started going back to
school october november you know what
kids are around each other
by the way in my heist in my kids school
they just shut down high school
high school has to go home because three
kids got covered so they shut down the
whole high school
yeah so they send the high school home
in texas to private school
but everybody else is still going to
school but high school because they're
playing around they're together they're
playing sports whatever they're doing
they shut it down right so
but you know the data doesn't show more
people are dying i'm
i'm getting your shows we're getting
more i get it i get it i get my question
what i'm saying is this what would you
rather have
we shut down we don't shut down gdp
grows at
you know two percent right yeah
we shut down for a month gdp grows
at 10 percent what would you rather have
that's not a
realistic option how is the gdp going to
grow on over a lockdown i i don't think
that'd be like saying would you like to
have a lot uh in the country but you're
guaranteed to have a winning lottery
ticket or would you rather
not have that well the gdp
lockdown is bad no other way around it
gdp in the second quarter
went down 34 right
went back up 35 and q3 my question is
if we lock down but gdp is able to grow
because they get a hold of this
no no gdp doesn't grow if you lock down
gdp only grows if you send free money
out that's how we grow
okay so we're going into more there's
going to be another package it's not
going to get approved if senators owned
on the other side
there's still going to be a stimulus not
the size it'll be at least a trillion
but all i'm saying is if experts not
talking heads like us over bro
you're saying that a potential lockdown
you're forgetting these are not
listen just so you know lockdown
benefits me
let me tell you selfishly so a lockdown
benefits me tremendously
more money in the stimulus benefits me
tremendously in millions of ways
we had the biggest month in the history
of the company when there was lockdown
selfishly it benefits me but it crushes
restaurants
it crushes small businesses do you know
how hard so so let me give you a little
bit more perspective
so you know when you start a business
how hard is it to keep a business
running and flowing
you know how hard it is very hard very
hard you know what's even harder
when you go out of business and try to
start another one when your business
goes out of business
what's your next move what's the first
thing you do when your business goes out
goes out of business what's the first
thing you got to do
try another one i guess no you get a job
you go get a job to save money because
all your savings was in that business
so the only reason you went out of
business because you ran out of money
if you have money you would have never
ran out of business yeah but these
businesses that are operating at 50
capacity yeah okay what if they continue
to operate at
50 percent capacity if you shut down
they're done
their margins are still 100
stimulus how much stimulus you're going
to give them to stay in business if it's
for a month
i've been looking at office space left
and right you know what landlords have
been saying
we're given 25 discount for people that
are struggling
25 they're not saying hey it's okay it's
25 25
the other business that took a big hit
his business didn't take the 25
hit the other guy took an 80 hit so he
took an 80
head on revenue and profits but you're
getting a 25 savings on the lease you
got to pay
you're out of business buddy such basic
stuff what kind of business are they
possibly doing at 50
capacity let's just let's because you're
desperate you need any kind of money
to try to stay afloat and you're trying
to make your business stay alive
with your savings your you're saying if
there's one month
of lockdown yeah i'm posing a question
yeah it's hard
and they give you money they give you
money they're not giving you enough
money 800 billion is nothing
you're saying 800 billion they're saying
it could be 1.5 trillion that's nothing
to who though what do you mean to
everybody a lockdown is a horrible thing
how do you keep a business going on bro
for one month here guys we're not
talking about for six months
do you really believe shutting down the
country is a good thing
right now i mean literally airlines got
crushed
good news we got vaccines coming up
stocks went up it's good
people are excited phenomenal you want
to shut down for four to six weeks
and by the way you know how you shut
down the economy for 90 days
you know how you shut down the economy
for 90 days guess how you shut down the
economy for 90 days
first you convince people to agree to
four to six weeks that's how you shut
down the economy for 90 days do you
understand what i just said
here's how you do it you're saying it's
a slippery slope no no here's how you do
it you shut down economy for 46 weeks
but the case is all stirred there we
need to go we're almost there
let's go four more weeks yeah that's
what they did last night that's exactly
what's happening in california that's
what they do
every single week and every single month
man i'm not saying we should do it i
know you're saying if the numbers know
what you're doing
tom you know who else who doesn't know
you you're saying it's so matter of fact
but i can't
i can't control myself when someone is
advocating to shut the country down
it makes no sense i'm i'm uh i'm i'm
i'm with you tremendously on not doing
that i think what needs to happen look
when we're having a conversation about
new york what'd you say
you gave perspective your perspective
was what you wanted your grandma to die
okay you don't want your grandmother to
die if they come to thanksgiving so what
did i say
let's say are you guys still gonna have
the gatherings maybe you don't know
about your grandma maybe you go to the
grandma and check on him and you leave
right maybe some people are not gonna do
that so the grandpa
like the other day tico was sick okay
he had a flu 100 degrees he likes to
sleep with his papa i when i say you're
not sleeping with papa tonight he says
why not i said because your dad's uh
your papa cannot get uh
the fever he says okay you're right you
know what he does he goes upstairs and
you know what he does he leaves his bed
then he goes and sleeps by himself on
another bed you know why
he says i don't want dylan to get sick
look at this freaking kid
he said i don't want dylan to get sick
freaking tickle man do what he thinks
what i'm trying to tell you is people
will think the right way to make the
decision to not
hurt their 85 year old grandma or
grandpa people can do the right things
you don't have to shut down the economy
when the rest of us are going to be okay
working
don't get me wrong there's a big
community in america that secretly would
love another shutdown
i know them who are those people same
people when the guy was giving me a
haircut with michael rapatoni and one of
the guys that was here saying
i'm making more money than ever because
of the freaking stimulus and the loving
life i have more cash than ever before
and i said wow what a freaking shame
that the economy is paying people
that we're not even making half this
money they're paying them twice the
money they're making right now just
because it stimulates you know how many
people but people are looking for a
shutdown
many people two-thirds of people we as
we establish making more money
you